would you rather lose all your old
memories or never be able to make new
ones
the past or the future
no i mean i can't lose my memories
all of them that makes me who i am
but you wouldn't be able to make new
ones
you wouldn't be so you'd be living in
the moment non-stop with all the
all the
but you did say you're in a really good
place so maybe this is a pretty good set
of memories you got you got all these
yeah
i mean you just
that's a nightmare
you just created a nightmare for me
that's a nightmare the choice the choice
is a nightmare yeah
you're [ __ ] either way
it's already beautiful it's a kind of
death
not being able to make new memories
that's it that's all you got yeah you
get to relive the memories you have
as a science guy let me ask you a
question sure
are you afraid to die
yeah of course i'm i'm not of course i
am i think about it every day
yeah i yeah i meditate on my on my
mortality all the time right it doesn't
make any sense it's terrifying it's
terrifying and because
are you terrified because of the unknown
or because you believe
it's nothingness
the unknown but my best guess is that
it's something like nothingness
and that nothingness is so terrifying
yeah the infinity of the nothingness
yeah yeah but ram das says and this is
something that i always you know ramdas
yeah ramdas says
he believes that death
is like removing
a tight shoe
like release
like ah
that could be it too i think maybe when
we die
that's initially maybe the last feeling
that we have
is release
and then if that happens and there's
nothingness i think that's cool
well no that that has to do more with
the actual feeling of death which i
think some people are afraid of the
experience to make sure it's
it's a it's a
it's one of
release like you said yeah but the
existential aspect that you no longer
exist
like all the [ __ ] you're doing kind of
assumes you'll live forever
right like you don't really can't like
all the your career and all that kind of
stuff
you probably will be forgotten i know
like completely
erased yeah so all you have is a few
moments in this life a few moments of
joy a few moments of trauma
of suffering and that's it i know but
here's the and you're wasting your time
today talking to me and then you have
you have a few such moments you'll do a
couple hundred more podcasts
and then you'll be dead
no because this right here dude right
is
human
number one
i walked through a little fear today so
i learned some things right
i'm talking to a science guy which i
never thought i could you're the first
scientist i've ever talked to yeah right
you get a diploma at the end of this oh
good and there's i i believe that there
was a connection
right not in the gateway not a gateway
non-gay
connection right um
in certain circumstances i probably
would blow you
would you in a certain circumstances
like if we were the last two people on
planet earth and stuff like that sure
yeah yeah but yeah those are probably
the only ones but uh or like somebody
put a gun to my eyes you've got to blow
lex okay yeah kind of all right yeah
yeah i'm turned on right now
yeah
let me ask you one
one question go ahead what do you think
is the meaning of life
my [ __ ] that's the last one yes this
is the last one yeah what do you think
why are we here
why are you here why are we here does
any of it make sense i i think
ultimately
here's the what's why i like life in
general is what we talked about like we
view death
there is a mystery there
there's a wonderment to it right so it's
like when i walk outside you know and i
look at the trees and i look at
buildings that man made these buildings
and you know i look at the universe and
i look in the sky and i don't really
completely comprehend what's going on
right it's just so in i'm in awe of all
of it right
and i don't have any answers right but
that i think is what the meaning of life
is is to be in awe of it and
the wonder of it all
and
it's just amazing yeah just open your
eyes to the wonder of it yeah
while we're still here yeah bobby uh
it's a huge honor to finally meet you
i've been a fan for many many years
um it's an honor that you would even
consider blowing me in the correct kind
of circumstances i think you would blow
me in the right circumstances i think
that's the definition of love
bobby thanks so much
you